this is going to be so much fun all
right welcome back last night was
music's biggest night and one of my
favorite artists siza graced viewers
with a special performance from the
Grammy house presented by MasterCard
siza actually created a song called Drew
Barrymore I don't know how I got so
lucky I did the music video for
it but that was a while ago and she has
continued to transcend in such
magnanimous ways in fact I think she was
the most nominated artist at the
grammies with about nine
nominations so s's love for our mother
earth came to her life in her
performance and it was all in support of
Master card's commitment to Forest
restoration through the Priceless Planet
Coalition and I'm so happy that we
partner with MasterCard to bring you a
behind the scenes peak of Sis's debut
performance of her song Saturn and
joining us is a DieHard scissor fan
because I don't want to be the only one
out here she shares the love um for the
environment um and actually became a
farmer at age 22 please welcome Cheyenne
[Applause]
Sundance I'm appreciating everything you
do for our planet but I also appreciate
everything you do for our eyes with your
amazing Style thank you I I feel like I
might as well dress like the rainbow If
I Grow the
rainbow what inspired you to start your
journey I finished high school and I was
like well what am I going to do I
decided I really like the environment
and I wanted to backpack so I went to
British Columbia which is like a really
really green province in Canada I
backpacked worked on some Farms came
back to Toronto where I was born and
raised and I said might as well start a
farm and I did that at 22 is it
fulfilling is it challenging it's hard I
have over 100 CSA shares and a CSA is
like a produce box right community
supported agriculture almost every day
I'm harvesting out in the field at 5:00
a.m. packing the greens putting them in
a bag delivering them it's really
beautiful though because you get to make
beautiful food from that okay well sza
and MasterCard heard your story and sent
you an autograph photo and then seeds
from her actual Grammy House Performance
because her dress was made um of
plantable seed
thank you so thank you Angel oh thank
you also our show wants to donate $5,000
to help you and your farm continue to
grow and I'm going to double that so
that's
$10,000 I'm going to be able to buy a
new Amendment for the tractor really
yeah I'm going to be able to not have to
hand plow the fields as many more really
yeah yeah thank you so
[Applause]
much I'm so in awe of the way that you
are living your life and when you
painted that picture it transcends from
here's a 22-year-old farmer to here is
this beautiful human being who is giving
back and it's so inspiring and yet
you're not talking the talk you're
walking the walk yeah and cute and cool
boots too yeah yeah you are all right
well says's outfit Incorporated actual
tree seeds so if you want to own a
plantable piece of her out head over to
mastercard's Instagram post of sz's
grammy House Performance for more
information um It also says in the
monitor there's a surprise I don't know
what I guess that's that's surprise
means you don't know what Happ I wish I
could be there in person but I still
wanted to pop in and say thank you and
your show for supporting me and
MasterCard we joined forces to raise
awareness for the prices planed
Coalition and we had such an amazing
performance last night I don't know if
you caught the seated outfit but we sent
a little something for you and I hope
you let love
it oh my God so great is there anything
you want to say to her uh thanks for
your cool style and thanks for your
amazing music it's great to listen to a
venam in the field harvesting
kale well I can't match that I love you
and I love you Cheyenne and thank you to
MasterCard for doing something so
beautiful with such beautiful people
we'll be right back thank you
I
[Music]
got